[Música]
[Aplausos]
no mires son 80 y es algo mas que
40 años pero apareció la regla
fui al medico y medidas rutinas dos
posibilidades un arte y convertido en
una señora mayor recibiendo un tratamiento
Iba a mandar y perea para salir de
consultar como una mujer joven
Según se informa menopáusica, estaba feliz y
vio la economía hace menos de 40 años
tirar una medalla de bronce
algunos tratamientos espero no sentir
joven enseñando que solo robin experiencia de
estar allí y muchos amigos sobre todo
buenos consejos de profesionales a los que
entrevistado para escribir un libro en
condujo a este título que tiene razón sonrió
atleta muy caro
queríamos y terminamos viendo un marcado
Conozco los temas que identifican a la pf
y la menopausia queríamos recordar la
mujer que impide un nuevo paso
queríamos divertirnos lo lograremos
un poco más y hemos aprendido un equipo
que cuando te tengamos muchos años
fue el primero del taller el ultimo msj y
participación en lo que ayuda en los 100
metros en algunas cosas para poder 29 -
la agenda y por una vez debe estar ocupado
nosotros un poco lo mismo y sus planes
que tenemos pendiente entre otras cosas
cosas tan importantes como por ejemplo
en las regiones de méxico - la agenda es
este sentimiento de culpa de recordar
Realmente tuve que tomar una pastilla
collar y cuadros que mirar me hace parar
cuerpo y pronto tendrá que tomar un
la píldora no es un negocio estable de
tratamiento hormonal sustituto del aceite
de estrógenos porque al fin y al cabo si tenemos que
conjunto con nacional brasileño en
ayuda a las mujeres
cuando tenemos menopausia esto es lo que hacemos
queremos en el entrenamiento y eso afecta a la
pato circulatorio afectado por ozzy mil
años sobre nosotros son el foco
y está ahí en la relación entre estos
diversos tratamientos hormonales sustitutivos
ir allí y el cáncer de mama no es
demostró que la relación causa-efecto no es
probado y realmente y esta probado es que
estos tratamientos del suelo pueden enviar una
médico
no vayas aquí a estudiar amigos piensa
todos estos años de terapia de amigos famosos
que en este momento lo que para protegernos y
recuperar amigos porque sentimos
cuando nos damos cuenta de que muchos de los
las preocupaciones que tenemos no son problemas
verdadero
son cosas que pasan a todos
mujeres a pesar de muchos amigos
deja caer amigos en el nivel humano de la vida y
en este momento son precisamente porque este
Comienza la temporada con más ganas que nunca
los proyectos sin el proceso se refiere
a un lado todas las familias que estaban
¿Hay algún otro lado para recuperarlos?
Creo que fue un error porque después de todo es
muchas veces la persona piensa que dormimos
si nos levantamos todos los dias mas o menos
todos los días lo que me está pasando
collar de doctor que no contará minton
ex marido eso es todo
y después de todo te estamos contactando en tu
maridos en estas paginas de las nuevas porque
solo se lo que esta pasando
entiende que vamos a hablar con
marcia mañana por la noche
y sobre todo sabrán ayudarnos a dejarnos
siempre vimos que nuestro libro debería leer
también en los hombres para que
aprender no entiende todo para que nosotros
ayuda si los problemas no tenemos que
explicar por qué de repente no dejas el
su fundador que este pico y la presentación de informes
con menopausia y la conocida que no
en los expertos nos dicen que no es
necesita un poco de eta y también de
rana se come todo por enfadarse un
poco ejercicio pero una rutina
flexible sintió que de 90 a
empresa y simular nuestra idea
es la sinopsis que tus primeros quieren
Sé que el gobierno estaba pensando en
probar una supuesta cultura y se acabó
con todo el juego
así que cada vez que pienses que mañana en
tu mejor día para pensar de nuevo
sufrido que volverse en contra del jugador de
gracia
tengo un ejercicio que es facil
practicar en cualquier momento del día
prácticamente cualquier situación y siempre
o casi siempre por sexo porque
porque es y todo sexual es evitar
el musculo de la pagina
y como todo bíceps y tríceps
como en los gluteos mas sierra de cinta
funciona pero es gracias a la falta de
estrógeno en el cuerpo de la mujer a cuerpo
asi que la hembra tambien y cuanto
cuanto más sexo se practique, mejor y más a
entrando ahí también está la química del
pavo extremo así que ahí es donde estamos
hablando de este sexo y cómo
también trabaja para mejorar
autoestima y quererlo porque es dificil
con este vaivén de estrógeno en
definitivo
mantener los niveles de autoestima que
entendemos los límites apropiados verdaderos
que solo de pensar en correr
tanto física como mentalmente
Ya tengo una parte importante es
contribuir de manera importante a mantener
autoestima en el momento de la menopausia
antes aplicado a nosotros este consejo es mio
me gusta y mi gusto
una de las madres que tenemos que repetirnos
todos los días cuando veíamos
las preguntas eran demasiado ruidosas en peru lima
las situaciones que son capaces de llevar
selectivo mejor trabajado por ejemplo
sobre pavo lo que abre el libro está en
mente porque tampoco fue un sueño
porque nos atamos en camisa de dolor
porque no sentimos combustible dentro como
botánica en el punto de la firma de jackson
y que entregará y cururu como el sur es el
que nos hizo perder un clásico porque
no elegimos a eta en Salvador y Recife
revela oro y hydratta y seguro
que todos los presentes en la sala
dispensación y los toques estéticos que
los toques esteticos tambien lo que no es
no hay pecado si consulta a un
experto y moderación y
naturalmente, especialmente que no tenían
tres son valores muy importantes con
el problema del cuidado físico está en
atención psicológica
Esta es la razón por la cual la pregunta fundamental en este
tiempo de vida la relación que contraen
desaparecido para es soportar cualquier
comprar problemas cotidianos y fundamentales
y para prevenir los tres que a menudo
el collar que es mas presidente
la depresión que está experimentando y
en este momento de la vida
por lo tanto personal fundamental 0
esa es toda la ruta de los estados que era
nuestro objetivo
cuando empezamos este libro tengo
hecho y es en este punto que es importante que
creemos que provoca muchas veces ni siquiera
ni siquiera somos conscientes de que todos
las cosas que estamos entendiendo
tiene que ver con como es con la menopausia perder
así que no ganamos nada enlazando desde
menopausia con el bg tratando de extender
silencio sobre este tema
seamos los otros y demos la
mujeres que nos entenderán y bebé
el futuro es definitivo porque sabemos que
en esta época
seguimos siendo manejados como sea posible
nosotros quienes somos nosotros quienes seremos
combinar son muy curiosos también
una de las rutas de la frivolidad y que ha
50 terminales con siglas como what is
muy positivo
no hay equipos y límites no significa
Nunca quise irme cuando queremos establecer
que pensar pero ay que soñar
ahí queda lo que queda por terminar
terminar un libro en profundidad
invierno descubrir tierra adentro
habitaba un gran entorno neumático
[Aplausos]